[Music]
hey guys this is jake from geek culture
and we are back with another unboxing
this time the elden ring collectors
edition so we have it right here let's
take a quick look at the box some nice
art some description about the game but
let's get right to it the stuff that
you're here for the collector's edition
just gonna put it down man handle this
box oh it's like that uh
hey guys
i expected it to be one whole box but
apparently i'm as surprised
as ever okay we're gonna take a look at
the first box here
open it up perfect we got the art book
here 40 pages of beautiful elden ring
art right here
let me take a look at a few pages so
that we don't spoil anything for you
guys
very nice art here
and i expected the game looks awesome
we got a very nice elden ring steelbook
you might think hey is there a game in
the steelbook no
but
we do have a copy of the ps5 version
right here
let's take a look inside got this got
early purchase bonus some dlc there
and then also included is a nice card
for the digital soundtrack for elden
ring there you have it that first box
it's all settled now we're going to take
a look at this big boy
open up
look at that
this is i'm gonna get the name wrong
what's her name again
millenia
millennia the seventh blade of uh
michaela
michaela michael michaela as you have
seen in some of the elden ring trailers
already
oh there break something no
okay good she's gonna appear in the game
as one of the bosses got her severed
blade over here quite fitting for her
name that's my cable yeah really malania
the server
correct with a severed blade here blade
of michaela which is melania the severed
oh she's known as the player
she's millennia the server wait how much
is it nobody knows where's the box oh
it's really just okay correct so she is
millennia the severed but also known as
the blade of
michela
so obviously she's a
kind of major
character in the game
uh
she's a boss character that you'll meet
seen some of the trailers you've seen
her fighting with general radan
so it's technically her fault that you
know the world is kind of screwed up at
this moment you can see it fits
perfectly into the box that it comes in
so you have some
nice scenes that you got here there's a
full diorama so as you can see
our dear milena the severed we've got a
nice prosthetic arm here
we can't move it unfortunately but if
you've seen the trailers yeah she get um
cut off by general redund but she keeps
on fighting there's some burnt scars on
her neck here
the scene the bass is yeah pretty much
what you can see in eldon ring a lot of
death
a lot of mud a lot of grime
she looks really ornate in
you know her
armor i guess now this is probably
something that you can get in the game
we're not too sure i'm sure you would
tell us in the comments
and on her back you can see
probably the sigil of
michaela i hope
since she is known as the blade of
maquila we don't know what michaela is
actually it could be a kingdom it could
be a god it could be somebody else we
don't know so if you're wondering how
the um millennia the seventh collectible
statue compares to the rest of uh
i guess the legacy of from software we
have a statue from the collector's
edition from dark souls 2 as well as the
dark souls 3 one so the warrior knight
as well as the red knight here so as you
can see they're not exactly
on the same scale
because millennia is definitely much
taller and bigger in the game so we
expect that to be in real life as well
she stands at uh 23 centimeters tall
compared to the rest she's a little bit
small
but in terms of how
the quality of the materials that are
used
in this figure definitely looks more
high-end compared to the previous ones
the
base itself is a little more detailed
not just plain rocks and stuff like that
her armor
you know her the construction of her
hair fingers everything the details are
really really great on this collector's
edition for alden ring so i would say if
you're you know a fan of from software
games and you're planning to get alden
ring this is a good addition to your
collection
now we should point out that
other than functioning as a great
scene
for your statue there is a passage here
behind on the box that houses millennia
it's probably more fantasy stuff that
you guys can read
and see from our video but yeah it kind
of foretells
the elden ring and its importance to the
world
and you know with it being broken and
you as the tarnish is your job to gather
the pieces and claim the title of elden
lord so there you have it
if you're interested in more
collectibles obviously please do check
out our unboxing of the regala and
collectors edition for horizon forbidden
west but as of right now we are focusing
all attention on eldon ring which is out
25th of february
right
tomorrow yeah yeah
all right tomorrow yeah if you want to
learn more about the game be sure to
visit uh geekhouja.com and read our
review we spent about 60 to 70 hours and
we're still not anywhere near the end
which is astounding this is probably why
elden ring is one of the most highly
rated games of all time
with plenty of tents across the board
and for us here geek culture will give
it about i think a 9.6
so yeah it's definitely a great game to
check out especially if you own
the current gen consoles loading times
are really fast
and uh you can get right back into the
action as you die and die and die again
until next time this is jake from geek
culture and we'll see you at the next
one
[Music]
you